l'énergie la défense et la coopération
dans le domaine de l'espace au coeur des
pourparlers du président russe vladimir
poutine et le premier ministre indien
narendra modi le dirigeant russe se
déplace ce lundi dans la soirée à new
delhi pour une visite de travail prévue
de longue date mais repoussée à cause de
la pandémie de coronavirus un échange
d'une grande importance pour les deux
chefs d'état selon iouri ouchakov
conseiller du président la rencontre se
tiendra un format tête à tête des
accords doivent être également signé à
lors de cette rencontre écoutez on
coopère dans divers secteurs dans divers
domaines dont l'énergie nucléaire et
l'espace en témoigne la dizaine
d'accords bilatéraux assez importants y
compris les accords semi-fermée qui ont
été préparés seront signés pour la
visite les parties continuent à
travailler sur ces accords nous sommes
convaincus que l'ensemble des accords
sera formalisée dans le cadre de la
visite une commission russo indienne sur
la coopération militaire se réunira
également new delhi en présence du
ministre russe de la défense sergueï
choïgou et son homologue indien elle
sera suivie d'une rencontre entre les
chefs de la diplomatie et de la défense
des deux pays la visite de vladimir
poutine intervient alors que la russie a
commencé la livraison à l'inde de
systèmes de défense antiaérienne s 400
triumph la première unité doit être
livré d'ici à la fin d'année la russie
et l'inde ont signé un contrat pour cinq
complexes s-400 en octobre 2018 pour
montant de 5,4 milliards de dollars